[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
عام
2013 عاده امل من الابتعاد بتخصص علوم
الحاسب والذكاء الصناعي كانت تحلم بمشاريع
بحثيه جدا متخصصه في تطوير الذكاء
الاصطناعي لخدمه اللغه العربيه تخصصها
الدقيق
عرض عليها وظيفه في جوجل فرع ديمبرا وايضا
في شركه تتبع الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن امل
اثارت انها تعود الى الوطن لخدمه المشاريع
في البحثيه في الوطن
اول ما وصلت امل الى الرياض قامت قدمت
مشروع بحثي على مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
العلوم والتقنيه وحظي المشروع على قبول
بنسبه 100% وكان قيمته اكثر من مليون ريال
في ذاك الوقت لكن
[تصفيق]
الامور لا تسير كما يريد الانسان بعدها
باشهر حصل حادث مروع لابنها انس
هذا الحادث ادى الى فقد الفقره يعني
الفقره الاولى من العمود الفقري تزحزحت عن
مكانها انكم بليت انجري
للنخاع الشوكي لكن هذا الحادث بعد هذا
حادث اصبح انس لا يستطيع الحركه الكلام
التنفس
ولا ولا اي شيء حتى الاكل ما يستطيع انه
ياكل ظل انس في العنايه المركزه سته اشهر
وكانت امل برفقته طبعا انس هي انس وامل
امل هي انا وابني انس هو المعني هو كان
ذلك قبل
كان ذلك تقريبا قبل عشر سنوات من الان
طيله اقامه انس في المستشفى واجهت عده
تحديات وكان يعني غير التحديات الطبيه
والمشاكل
والمعجزات سلسله المعجزات اللي حدثت لانس
يمكن تخصصكم الطبي يقول لكم انه سي1 من
الحالات الصعبه جدا وقد يكون لا ينجو لكن
بفضل من الله ورحمته انس نجاه
وتعافى واصبح قابله التاهيل
وسلسله من
يعني العلاجات التي عملناها في الداخل
والخارج لمساعده انس للعوده الى الحياه
بفضل الله
طبعا كانت شكرا كانت العباره اللي دائما
كنت ارددها هذا امر الله اي شخص يجي يمي
في العنايه هذا امر الله انا لم اصنع انس
بنفسي حتى يعني احزن عليه بحزن انه يفقدني
قدراتي انما هذا انس من صنع الله والله هو
اللي كتب لانس انه يصير في هذه الحاله انا
هنا لمساعدته وتمكينه ليعيش وكان هذا
الكلام دائما اقوله لكل من يزورني في غرفه
الترقيد او في العمله المركزه وهذا الحمد
لله اعطاه دفعه ايجابيه لانا وجميع
العائله انه نعيش ونتواصل مع ناس بشكل جيد
ولله الحمد
كان الدكتور لما يدخل عندي في العلم
المركزه يسالني انا كيف انس واقول انا مش
انس انس هذا اسال انس فكان يلتفت لانس
مستغرب انه كيف اتواصل معاه
كيف اتواصل كيف يتواصل انس مع الاطباء مع
الممرضين مع الاهل ما في لا صوت ولا حركه
ولا اي شيء هنا بدات القصه وبدانا رحلتنا
الطويله مع التقنيات المساعده التي ساعدت
انس على التواصل في جميع حالاته يوم كان
لا يستطيع يحرك ولا شيء الى ان حرك الاصبع
الى ان اصبح يتحرك راسه الى اصبح يبتسم في
جميع الحالات التي كان انس يعني عفوا كان
انس يعني مر فيها كنا دائما استخدم وسائل
تواصل مختلفه
طبعا رحله العلاج لانس داخل السعوديه
وخارج السعوديه تقريبا امتدت الى سنتين
ونصف
ممزوجه بالثقه التفاؤل الصبر
وان التمكين انا اريد ان امكن انس اريدها
ان يعود للحياه
طبعا كل مشاريعي توقفت لاني انا كرست كل
شيء لانس وبما انه انا تخصصي اي تي وايضا
في الذكاء الاصطناعي فكان دائما تفكيري
كيف الذكاء الصناعي والتقنيات تساعد
الانسان ان يتواصل ويخرج الى الحياه
[تصفيق]
التواصل نعمه سواء كان بالكلام او الاشاره
او اي وسيله اخرى هناك حالات شلل جلطه
توحد
اللي ما يسمع او حتى الذي لا يرى كلها
اداء يعني ادوات افقدت الانسان التواصل زي
الناس الطبيعيا كيف يتواصلون كيف يدرسون
كيف يعملون بشكل طبيعي كيف يحققون
منجزاتهم احلامهم كلها اسئله التقنيات
المساعده توفر لها حلول
ومن هنا بدات رسالتنا في ان تتحقق عام
2019 اسسنا اول جمعيه للتقنيات المساعده
بتصريح من وزاره الموارد البشريه للتركيز
على هذا الجانب التقنيات المساعده بين
التقنيه والتاهيل لتسد الفجوه ما بين
التاهيل
والخدمه الصحيه وايضا بين التقنيه والتطور
التقني
طبعا في جمعيه تواصل
في السعوديه تقريبا سبعه بالمئه من
السعوديين من ذوي الاعاقه سواء كانت اعاقه
واحده او اكثر
والدراسات اثبتت ان واحد من كل خمسه معرض
ان يكون من ذوي الاعاقه عند كبر سنه وهذا
شيء ملاحظ في كبار السن يفقدون احد
وظائفهم ليصبحوا من ذوي الاعاقه اذا حنا
نتكلم عن شريحه كبيره جدا اين التقنيه في
الموضوع التحول الرقمي التحول التقني
التحول الصحي
جمعيه تواصل تحقق مستهدفات رؤيه المملكه
2030 في التحول الصحي وايضا جوده الحياه
جمعيه تواصل حققت خلال فترات القليله
الماضي السنوات الماضيه عده
عده انجازات
وكانت مرت بعده صعوبات ايضا لما اتجهنا
الى المجتمع للكلام عن نريد ان نساعد ذوي
العقبه التقنيه كان مزيج من الخيال كيف
للتقنيه ان تساعد
يعني لا يمشي ان يصل لذا يتكلم ان يتواصل
وما الى ذلك لكنه فعلا هذا ممكن
ونستطيع انت من خلال التقنيات ان نمكن
الاشخاص للوصول الى الدرجه المقبوله في
التواصل والتاهيل والتمكين
في جمعيه تواصل اكثر من 20 موظف لكن لدينا
اكثر من 400 متطوع ومتطوع متخصص علاج
وظيفي تواصل هندسه رقميه طبيعي جميع
التخصصات الطبيه كل التخصصات ذات العلاقه
تحت سقف واحد جمعيه تواصل اسست اول مركز
لجمع جميع
التخصصات تحت سقف واحد لخدمه هذه الفئه
استفاد من جمعيه تواصل اكثر من 400 مستفيد
صار عندنا مشاريع منها مشروع المتحدث
العربي الذكي هذا المشروع استفاد منه الان
55 الف من اطفال التوحد وايضا كبار السنه
الغير قادره على التواصل وهو استخدم
الذكاء الصناعي ايضا لدينا منصه لذوي
الاعاقه هي اول منصه عربيه لايصال جميع
المعلومات والمعرفه لذوي اسمها منصه حياه
تستطيعون ان تبحثون عنها ايضا دربنا اكثر
من 115 اخصائي في يعني على التقنيات وكيف
ممكن تساعد التقنيات عده اشخاص للوصول الى
المستهدفات
جمعيه تواصل ايضا لديها عده انجازات ولله
الحمد مسرعه رواد التقنيه اول معمل
ابتكاري وقفي جائزه الابتكار الاجتماعي
المركز الاول في تحدي ابشر وهذا
المسابقه كانت لجميع
المقترحات لتطور منصه ابشر
واقترحنا خدمه عملاء ذكيه للصم باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي دون الحاجه لمترجم ولله
الحمد حصلنا على المركز الاول بنسبه كامله
من جميع لجنه التحكيم في المسابقه 20 22
مثلنا السعوديه في دبي في معرض
الاكسبوديسي
كمشروع نوعي للابتكار الاجتماعي باستخدام
التقنيات الحديثه واخر ما حصلنا عليه في
رمضان قبل عده اسابيع
الاعتماد من مبادره سند محمد بن سلمان
الله يحفظه لتمكين ذوي الاعاقه في التواصل
والتعليم والعمل
لخدمه هذه الفئه مشروع جمعيه تواصل هو
مشروع نوعي ولله الحمد وهو زي ما ذكرنا في
الاول من الالم ممكن نخلق الامل وان شاء
الله هذا المشروع الوطني
بايدي سعوديه وموجات سعوديه مئه بالمئه
شكرا لكم واسعد بتواصل الجميع وايضا
الانضمامكم الى جمعيه تواصل كانت معكم امل
السيف والده انس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]